good afternoon afternoon I'm Matthew
Spalding associate vice president and
Dean of educational programs for
Hillsdale College in Washington DC
welcome to the Allenby kirby center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
hillsdale college is an independent
institution of higher learning found in
1844 by those believing that the
diffusion of learning is essential to
the perpetuity the blessings of civil
and religious liberty and so for a
hundred and seventy years we have been
without any government support providing
education liberal arts for students
regardless of race leader color we
continue to do so that commitment which
we hold very dear is represented today
especially in the person of the 12th
president of Hillsdale College well
recognized and with us here today from
Michigan dr. Larry R
the purpose the kirby center here in
Washington DC is to extend the college's
mission to the nation's capital by
teaching students citizens and political
leaders about principles and practices
of American constitutionalism and how to
understand and apply those principles in
today's politics in doing so we seek to
promote not polit policies are
partisanship but a statesmanship worthy
of American liberty and I'd like in that
in that sense of building statesmanship
recognized some friends of ours from
California rear several state
legislature California welcome to the
kirby center especially Senator Mike
Morell and his wife Joanie was sent to
their sons Hillsdale College thank you
as is our custom with these lectures a
Hillsdale student will actually
introduce today's speaker Michael a bang
is a junior majoring in politics and
minoring in business hillsdale college
taking classes this semester here at the
kirby center one of mine included so
excellent student he's interning for
representative Tim Hill olscamp of
Kansas as part of the Hillsdale whip
program prior to coming to Hillsdale
College he was a battalion data chief a
martial arts instructor a machine gun
instructor and machine gunner and radio
operator with rank of sergeant all in
the United States Marine Corps we thank
him for that service
thank you dr. Spaulding its privilege to
introduce today's speaker michael barone
is a leading american conservative
political analyst on dent pundit
journalists he earned a bachelor's
degree from harvard university in 1966
and a law degree from Yale he is the
principal co-author of the Almanac of
American politics and a regular
commentator on us selections and
political trends with Fox News Channel
over the years he has written for many
major publications including The
Economist the New York Times the Detroit
press american enterprise and the daily
telegraph of london in april of 2009 he
joined the washington examiner leaving
his position of 18 years at US news and
world report today he is a resident
fellow at the American Enterprise
Institute mr. Bruin has traveled to all
50 states and all 435 congressional
districts he has also traveled to 37
foreign countries reporting recently on
elections in Russia Mexico Italy and
Britain ladies and gentlemen please join
me in giving a warm welcome to Michael
Barone
well thank you very much I've never been
introduced by a machine gunner before
and the thank you indeed for your
service and I understand that you are
not an ex-marine because there is no
such thing as an ex-marine it's nice to
be with you in this room it's not a huge
room but then it's not very much smaller
than that one that we see in the picture
over there and as dr. iron said to me
we're still looking to try to accumulate
the talent that was there in that room
in 1787 I'm sure we've got some nascent
type of people congruence of that but
we're still working on it we're still
working on the on the on that in the
capital building not far away which is
perhaps appropriately under construction
or renovation at the present time the as
you said introducing me I've gone
through a kind of varied professional
career I've moved from one profession to
another each one of which tends to pay
less than the one before and have a
lower level of intellectual honesty and
integrity so I started off near the top
with the law then I went down a couple
of steps to political consulting and
then I descended a whole staircase down
to journalism and there's only one thing
left academia except of course for
Hillsdale College where he got faculty
members like my friend Paul ray who I
think is one of the leading scholars in
America of of our time we've we've just
had an election as many of you know we
had a former Speaker Nancy Pelosi
comment on it she said it wasn't a wave
it was just an ebb tide or something I
guess my response to that is to
posed the question did Custer lose at
Little Bighorn I think yeah it was a it
was a wave it's interesting the popular
vote for the House of Representatives
which has become a pretty good index 0
partisan and a large extent ideological
opinion in the country showed
Republicans apparently leading by 52 to
forty-five percent we're still waiting
for the count in some places including
California California has taken as long
as five weeks to count its votes in
Brazil where they had a recent election
they count them in five hours I'm
waiting for California to catch up with
the technological sophistication and in
advanced modern efficiency hope Brazil
but that appears to be the margins same
margin is in 2010 in 1994 there will be
more Republicans elected to the House of
Representatives this year than in any
year since 1928 and we have any people
here who were here in the nineteen
twenty-eight cycle at least sentient and
aware of it it's there will be more
Republicans in state legislatures than
at any time since the 1920s as well the
Republican Party has won a majority in
the Senate with a net gain of eight
seats confirmed in Alaska yesterday and
problem was certainly nine after the
Louisiana runoff december six it'll be
the largest net gain for any party in
senate seat since 1980 when the
republicans gained 12 in the same year
that ronald reagan was elected president
over jimmy carter now this is not a
final victory for the republican party
or for conservative principles the folks
over there did not design a system that
produces final victories for anybody
they designed a system of representative
government of checks and balances in
which there is always room for a change
in various directions
in for a creative statesmanship to lead
us in a better direction and but it is a
significant victory and one reason is
that it's we're in a period of street
party voting when I started off writing
my book that I'm co-author of the
Almanac American politics some 42 years
ago I like to say that it's highly
unusual for the first edition of a book
of this nature to have been written by
someone at the age of four when I
started writing this we were kind of a
split ticket country you had Republican
landslides for president 1972 1984 and
half the congressional districts that
voted for the Republican presidents
elected Democratic congressman that
doesn't happen anymore and it's an
interesting it's an interesting case
that st. Teresa of Avila said that the
most tragic prayers are answered prayers
the political scientists when I was in
school were calling for they said
wouldn't it be better in the United
States if we had one clearly
Conservative Party and one clearly
Liberal Party Gallup used to ask
questions on that on his pulse about
half of Americans in the late 40s early
50s said gee that would be a good idea
of course I think most of the political
scientists expected that the clearly
liberal party would win most of the
elections and that's one of the reasons
they wanted that well their prayers have
been answered we pretty much have that
we've got pretty ideologically coherent
parties and we've got a population which
while a lot of people say they're
independent and they vote for the man
not the party when you actually look how
they vote they voting all for the
Republicans are voting for all the
Democrats that is the pattern that we
see in this in the Congress that was
elected in 19 in 2012 showing my age by
starting off a year with 19 the anybody
ever do that you find yourself doing
that the in the Congress elected in 2012
we had a record number of low number of
split congressional districts at his
congressional districts vote for
president and one party congressman of
another was 26 out of the 435 districts
voted that way there were nine districts
that voted for Mitt Romney and elected
Democratic congressman six of them
elected republican congressman on on
last Tuesday but that that so we're we
are a straight ticket and so the party
score is a pretty good indication of
where we are and so we went into this
election the president won reelection in
2012 with fifty percent of the 51
percent of the votes at a time when his
job performance rating was fifty percent
in pre-election polls his job
performance rating was forty-two percent
and the exit poll is forty-four percent
basically many most of the results are
reasonably well predicted from that
statement the Republicans won or will
soon win all seven seats held by
Democrats and states that were carried
by Mitt Romney Alaska Arkansas Louisiana
december six Montana North Dakota South
Dakota West Virginia they won two seats
in in the states that were carried by
President Obama Colorado and Iowa and
they came very close and two others in
New Hampshire and unexpectedly in in
Virginia and the the Republicans held
threatened seats in Kansas Kentucky and
Georgia where the polls it was
interesting polls under predicted the
Republican candidates performance in
these seriously contested races the
polls actually were quite accurate
predicting the Democrats performance
mean Senator Mark Warner of Virginia
Democrat running for reelection who got
sixty five percent 2008 the polls showed
him at forty-eight percent you got
forty-nine percent he won 49 48 the
polls under counted at Gillespie's thing
I've got a column coming out in the
washington examiner examining this
phenomenon
to understand some of the election
reason some of the reasons why the polls
but basically in a wave year Democrats
get what their polling and Republicans
tend to do better in a Republican wave
here we get a democratic wave here like
we had in two thousand six or eight it
would be the other way around
governorships one of the things those
folks thought about Ian contrive to
create was a Republican which states
would be sovereign and would have their
own political thing political decisions
to make through Republican forms of
government which they're guaranteed by
the Constitution and it was generally
predicted the Republicans we're going to
lose governorships they did lose
Pennsylvania where the Republican
governor had been involved in the Penn
State situation that was not a big help
but Republicans retained the states of
wisconsin and michigan against heavy
opposition in wisconsin from the public
employee unions in michigan from the
private sector unions the bargaining
changes that scott walker put through in
wisconsin were officially ratified by
the voters and in fact his democratic
opponent even said she wouldn't change
them herself the right-to-work law that
was put in on side by Governor Rick
Snyder in Michigan was retained
government Republicans retained by solid
margins governorships of beleaguered
conservatives in Kansas in Georgia they
retained Florida although rick Scott the
Republican governor won by only one
percent for the second consecutive time
mr. Scott it's highly successful in
business and contributed 70 million
dollars to his first campaign which
enabled him to win with one percent and
it reminds me of the comment that John F
Kennedy made after he was elected
president by a narrow margin and
somebody said well your father finance
the campaign how come you did better and
he said well my father said I'll be
damned if I'll pay for a landslide
rick scott apparently operates on the
same philosophy republicans also gained
governorships in mayor Illinois
Massachusetts in Maryland they came very
close in Connecticut they lost in Rhode
Island but the Democratic candidate was
actually a tougher opponent of public
employee unions than the Republican
candidate there so demikhov's basically
have state government more than half of
Americans have got Republican governors
Republicans state Senate's Republican
state houses or assemblies or houses of
Delegates and Democrats do you have
seven states that only has 16 of the
nation's population of which almost all
of that is in California and we used to
want to saw off they very global what I
want us off the northeast coast and send
it out to sea we're hoping that when
seismic events produce the big one
coastal Cal will wave goodbye to coastal
California and we'll see I think these
victories represent about as
unequivocally as political campaign
results can represent in the message
everyday world a rejection of the big
government policies of the Obama
Democrats the Obama Democrats came to
office super majorities 2008 elections
2009 inaugural operating under an
assumption that particularly in times of
economic distress Americans would be
supportive of or amenable to big
government policies if you just give
them what Mitt Romney and felicitous Lee
called free stuff people were going to
be happy and delighted and pleased and
grateful and they learned that lesson in
many ways from the beautifully written
histories of the New Deal Arthur
Schlesinger and other writers these were
in their time were best-selling books
they they cemented this vision of the
1930s I tried to advance an alternative
vision of the 1930s in my book our
country the shaping of America from
Roosevelt to Reagan it has not had quite
best
towing capacity on Amazon the other day
I noticed that a copy was available for
11 cents I recommend that every
Hillsdale student should have one I'm
not sure that's going to give me you
know what a meal on Washington's Pasha's
restaurant but students can afford the
book now if your Amazon Prime it's going
to cost you less than them than than
four minutes on a DC parking meter so
the but I submitted a different version
and what i sent basically and I
fortified with this election results and
i can give you the kick you know
detailed comparisons of the 19 34 and 36
election results if anyone is interested
but the basically people may say
initially they like big government when
they see how it works out they don't
like it they recoil against that we see
this again and again in 1938 1946 1980
1994 and again in 2014 when they
actually see how it works when something
penetrates what the Obama care adviser
Jonathan Gruber called the stupidity of
the American people people don't like it
too much I think this came as a surprise
the Obama Democrats they thought the
stimulus package is going to be popular
they were spending lots of money you
know people will like it they thought
Obamacare would be popular you know they
still are occasionally writing columns
saying that well it's just on the brink
of popularity now and people like some
parts of it and that sort of thing this
Speaker Nancy Pelosi said that we would
learn what was in the act once it was
passed and that we would like it so far
those predictions haven't come true and
we are now sitting at four years and in
eight months after Obamacare was passed
that's an interesting half-life it has
not come true
they passed higher taxes on higher
earners after the 2012 election that'll
take that'll you know hit the
one-percent people will love that well
you didn't hear much about the stimulus
package about Obamacare about higher
taxes on high earners in from Democrats
in the campaign you did hear a lot
especially about Obamacare from
Republicans in this campaign the
Democrats talked about peripheral issues
they you know these people that want to
redistribute huge amounts of income and
penalize the top 1% you know impose
seventy-five eighty percent taxes on
them are all entranced with raising the
minimum wage when you look at what the
minimum wage actually does when you
raise it it basically has fast-food
customers subsidizing fast food workers
minus those workers who get laid off and
replaced by kiosks that really socks it
to the one percent it's it's a pathetic
public policy in terms of the stated
goals of these people you heard the
Democrats talk a lot about the war on
women out in Colorado narrow pro-choice
America which has taken abortion out of
its name ran ads saying that female
contraceptives would not be available in
Colorado and there would be a shortage
of condoms if Cory Gardner the
Republican was elected to the US Senate
well we've got a test case of that Cory
Gardner was elected to the US Senate
speculators who wanna perhaps respond to
these predicted shortages could put
their money on the table and see if
they're going to make some money doing
so it was pathetic and they you know the
Democratic senator mark Udall who had an
interesting record on a number of issues
spent more than half his ad money on the
war on women the Denver Post a liberal
editorial page called it a quote
obnoxious one issue campaign unquote
that's the pot
it's what happens to a party when its
major positions are not popular when it
can't talk about the major in central
issues because they don't work for them
they work against them and that sort of
thing you heard you know the the at the
same time as senate majority leader
harry reid was denouncing the the koch
brothers other major contributors to
conservative causes he was ladling out
the hundred million dollars pledged by
this san francisco billionaire tom
steyer who wants to oppose fracking and
so forth the democrats took the money
they didn't run anti-fracking ads turns
out that people actually want more
energy production and lower prices for
gasoline natural gas and oil they want
the jobs that can be created good-paying
jobs created by these things so i think
this is this is a case where the core of
the democratic party the black voters
and gentry liberals my friend Joel
Cochran's term Jed if you don't know
what a Gentry liberal is we can arrange
a bus to take you over to Georgetown and
you can talk to some of the residents
there the speaker nancy pelosi a Gentry
liberal beautiful house san francisco
the wine country you know so forth the
those are the two groups when barack
obama designed to state's own state
senate district in 2002 after the two
thousand census that with the group c
combined blacks majority for the
democratic south side of Chicago and
then north of the loop the Near North
Side rich liberal contributors that's
their policies aren't working for them
they gave you know they spending free
stuff Obamacare and so forth voters
don't appreciate it don't see it as
benefiting them see it as hurting their
situations see a big government is
performing poorly the
the other other issues that they go that
they've gone on this so-called war on
women what I call abortion absolutism
that's frayed and really isn't a winner
anymore you gun control they that is
repelling people and I think what we can
see what's happening if we look at two
critical groups of the electorate I've
got to watch an examiner column today
which is also a lead column in Real
Clear Politics calm that talks about
some of these things we were told after
the two thousand eight election that
Democrats were going to be a majority
party in America because Hispanics and
non-whites hispanics and Millennials
were two to one for Barack Obama in 2008
which is true and they were going to
vote that way forever and presto we were
going to have a Democratic majority in
the country because these are inevitably
increasing percentages of the total
electorate the last point is accurate
the first point is dubious and with
Hispanics you know I one of the Senate
race with the largest Hispanic
population was in Colorado and one of
the things we saw there is that abortion
absolutism did not work for them I don't
think they're really necessarily strong
abortion opponents this is not like a
calf Irish Catholic parish in the 1950s
as some conservatives portray them but
it's not really very relevant to their
situation gun control the democrats in
calif a colorado passed a gun control
bill two state senators who voted for
were recalled by the voters in replaced
by Republicans including a hispanic
state senator from forty two percent
Hispanic web low County that district
want Republican again in the election
the Democratic Democrats used to carry
pueblo county by twenty percent they
carried it by 1% this time the the anti
free of the the liberals
environmentalists and Colorado want to
put a ballot proposition on stopping
fracking they were persuaded by other
Democrats who were reading old and
decided that that wasn't one of God's
great ideas and pressured them to get it
off and basically when you look what
Hispanic voters want they want
absent education they want a chance to
move upward in society they're not
getting that from the Obama economy
they're not getting good education from
the teacher union control public schools
they want something different and if you
look over all the country hispanic vote
was 71 percent for obama over mitt
romney this time it was sixty-two
percent democratic that is buoyed up
words however by heavy Democratic
percentages over seventy percent
California New Jersey in New York which
have about forty percent of eligible
Hispanic voters if you look at Hispanic
voters in Texas in florida and colorado
and kansas in georgia in florida what
you see as the hispanic democratic
percentages are much lower those photos
are in play they care more about jobs
and education they hear about
immigration though they they care
somewhat about that we can discuss that
more perhaps but my point is this
they're not they did not hispanics in
america and the other subgroup we look
at sometimes asians my friend Ron
Brownstein likes to lump them together
with blacks as non-whites I think this
is a historical black Americans have had
a particular historic heritage going
back to slavery and segregation that is
unique in our country it's one that
Hillsdale College responded positively
to back in the 1850s if i'm not mistaken
and was a leader in moving towards civil
rights and equal rights in America
hispanics and asians in there a variety
of different subgroups there haven't had
that historic experience asian
immigrants that move here in america are
not directed to use separate restrooms
and drinking fountains they are not
prevented from voting by armed violence
and so forth to assume that they're
going to respond as black voters respond
assumes a similar historic experience
and I think it's just simply contrary to
fact proposition Millennials under-30s
2008 6632 Obama that was if you if you
take
the popular vote margin for Obama in
2008 among Millennials it amounted to
seven percent of the total electorate
the Democratic over Republican margin
that was Obama's total margin he carried
voters over 30 probably by 50 49 the
Republicans missed a chance to win that
election when they didn't pass a
constitutional amendment raising the
voting age to 35 well what are where
world where were Millennials this time
according the exit poll they were
Democratic 54-43 in house elections
that's a Democratic margin if you
measure it is the Democratic over
Republican margin as a percentage of the
total electorate it's not seven percent
it's 1.5% if you adjust for the fact
that you're going to have a higher
millennial turnout in a presidential
year than you had the off year which is
surely true it's two percent that is a
challenge for Republicans it's not
necessarily permanent death of the
Republican Party and I think here that
we're seeing an operation a basic
tension between the attitudes of this
generation towards their life projects
and the public policies of the Obama
administration the Obama Democrats
believe in centralized command and
control they believe in the stupidity of
the American people they believe that
enlightened experts who usually
translate as people we knew in school
can devise systems and so forth it can
help the ordinary person navigate
through the vicissitudes of life and
what they always insist is a complex
society turns out it's a little too
complex for them to understand as
Friedrich Hayek told us no central
planner can figure out everything about
a complex society and workings of free
markets free free rights of free
expression the rule of law enables
results to be much more optimal than
centralized commanding
but that's what they given them
centralized it was arguably working in
the grain with the grain of the changes
in society in the industrial ear if you
go about two hours east of hillsdale
college you'll see the ford rouge plant
in Dearborn Michigan Henry Ford built
that plant just a little less than a
hundred years ago it cost about 1
billion dollars in 1916 that was
actually a lot of money then they had a
workforce of 40,000 people i drew this
summer I was in Michigan where I grew up
I drove around the ford rouge plant of
the perimeter it's five point 0 miles on
the on the odometer to drive around that
plant in a big industrial area of 40,000
people the idea of centralized command
and control seemed to make sense we're
in a different age now we're in an
Information Age and the artifact of the
information age is not the ford rouge
plant 5 miles around 40,000 people
working there it's this that's got more
information available than was available
to all the centralized command control
people with the management the Ford
Motor Company the UI Auto Workers Local
ADA 600 etc they were operating in the
ford rouge plant and I think this
generation is a generation of people
that want to personalize the world they
want to have their own Facebook pages
their ipod playlist they want to make
their establish their own friendships
and their own networks and they are
seeking I think work and life paths that
will enable them to a chief satisfaction
through as my AEI president Arthur
Brooks says through earning success
earning success economically but also
earning success in terms of family
earning success by contributing to your
community earning success in voluntary
associations earning success god bless
us even working in government in
different ways that you can earn success
and they want ways
will maximize their own special interest
their own special talents this
administration's policies have not given
them much help we can see from the
sluggish economic growth figures that
the that you know instead of getting a
job finding work creating a job or jobs
that maximize your own special talents
that build on your own special interest
your own uniqueness is a human being in
a free society you take what you can get
in this one and you're grateful for that
increase in the minimum wage unless
McDonald's moves a kiosk in your place
and they they aren't very grateful for
this they are and so I think the
Millennials here are are are at odds
with this policy and I think this
election I think was a pre pewdie ation
of the of the of the Obama Democrats
public policies I don't think it's going
to be taken as an endorsement of
republican or conservative public
policies I don't think those policies
have been developed or presented I think
it gives Republicans not a mandate but
an opportunity an opportunity to advance
forward with public policies that work
with the grain of the character of our
society that work in an Information Age
that works to provide open the way
opportunities to people to maximize
their own special interests and special
needs and special gifts that they have
in and to develop them I think we've
seen some Republicans do this in state
governments in a variety of different
ways and those people were rewarded even
where some of those policies were
extremely controversial attacked as you
might imagine by all the press etc etc I
think that nationally we've got a
situation
that that where the Republicans have an
opportunity to policies that they back
in Congress and you know starting with
the and a no-brainer is like let's build
the Keystone pipeline pipelines are the
safest way to transport oil we've seen
the railroad Rex and so forth and and
moving on to other things we've seen
some Republicans in Congress advanced
interesting and important new ideas we
will see Republican presidential
candidates and I can name a baker's
dozen of them at this point and we will
see what they do it my old observations
is a one-time political consultant is
that what you need to do is a
presidential candidate there's a
candidate for governor executive office
is you need to come up with three or
four issues that are important to the
public where your views are basically in
line with the public and with the go
with the grain of change in society and
issue positions in what you really
believe and issues that can work a in
the primaries be in the general election
see and most important in governing it's
actually hard to do and it's a challenge
any presidential candidate looking back
on President Obama I don't think he
really did that I don't think there was
much issue content to his campaign it
was more look what a neat guy I am and
if you look at his record he's a person
that doesn't seem very interested in the
details of public policy I suspect this
room is not full of fans of Bill Clinton
but I think most of us would agree that
he was interested in public policy he
did know a lot about the details he
worked pretty hard at that this
president not so interested and we've
seen kind of the results we've got and
and we've seen increasing evidence of
the incompetents of big government I
won't go on much on the 2016
presidential election
we can talk more about that questions
but let me just leave you with some
thoughts that I've had about the the
capacity of big government and historic
comparison of today's information age
with the past's industrial age there
were 42 months between pearl harbor and
VE day wrote a column about this
recently I thought I'd better explain
what VE Day is a lot of people may not
know it Hillsdale I think they're going
to learn other places the idea of the
United States being victorious is not
something they really want to promote
you know were the bad guys in the world
for 42 months between VE Day and Pearl
Harbor in that time the United States
puts 16 million men and some women in
military uniform transported them around
the world to the shores of North Africa
Italy in Normandy to to to to Germany to
the Philippines of South Pacific Islands
the around the Pacific the we developed
with a wisdom of President Roosevelt was
that unlike his predecessor President
Wilson he didn't nationalized industries
he worked with the industries and gave
the industrial leaders the business
leaders the go-ahead to work and we
produce tens of thousands of airplanes
of ships hundreds of thousands of guns
tens of thousands of tanks we supplied
the world with food most of the free
world with food during that period of
time that's what Americans were able to
accomplish in fort for be in 42 months
government was a part of that we had the
government wasn't the only part of it
well there were 42 months between the
passage of Obamacare in march 2010 and
the rollout of healthcare.gov in october
2013 that's what government could have
got in 42 months there's there's
something wrong with this picture and I
think Americans are coming to realize it
I think the political this was a good
year for Republicans this was a good
year for concern
this was a good election year for
constitutionalism but these fights go on
and the outcomes are not certain I think
conservatives have now been given an
opportunity by the American people and
we'll see how well they handle it thanks
very much
I I think it's an issue of very little
importance I mean why are Democrats
picking up in this issue I used to you
know I'm a recovering pollster and if
you do polls you say okay what about
Thomas Piketty the French economist that
says we should tax people at eighty
percent let's pull that one how does
that do with the American people well
you know it doesn't do very well they
have one of these rap artists or
something was going over to Paris and
they said well do you approve of the
French government's policy of higher
taxes on rich people and he's home yeah
that's a great idea he says you have the
text there on income is now 75% and he
said whoa seventy-five percent that's
ridiculous minimum wage pulls well
people don't care you know it they were
they recognize perhaps just viscerally
there ain't very important if you want
to redistribute income if you want to
use government UK's to redistribute
income it's about the most ineffective
way you can do so you know it's
interesting that when Democrats pass an
increase in the minimum wage they never
almost never index it to inflation why
is that because then they wouldn't have
an issue of raising at two years and
four years from then or at some election
when they weren't doing well on other
issues and they wanted to bring up that
old warhorse the minimum wage federal
minimum wage stage it's 1938 that's not
exactly up to date and new
thank you soo reuter asking the question
there's a plan and I would even call it
a plot to bypass the Electoral College
in future yeah by having the electors of
each state committed to go along with
the popular vote of the country as a
whole some states have even passed laws
accepting that what you know about the
status of that and its future well it's
an attempt mostly by Democrats to
relitigate the 2,000 election and I
think like a lot of the sort of gimmicky
changes it may turn out to work against
the side that wants it if it ever got
put into effect you know some
Republicans could say well we should
elect the President by congressional
districts Mitt Romney carried 226
congressional districts Barack Obama
carry 209 for those of you who had new
math 226 is a larger number than 209 and
you know I don't think that's going to
come to anything you know there's an
argument for popular vote election of
the president but remember that we have
different vote systems run by the 50
states and bless them the District of
Columbia and you know we had the Florida
controversy and he had lawyers pouring
into each one of 67 counties seeds well
if we had a national popular vote there
are 3141 counties I think it's a I think
that ideas probably going nowhere and
it's just one of those things when you
try to try to relitigate an election
that you were upset about the outcome of
thank you in California we're changing
the rules making it easier to vote
same-day registration you can now post
mark your ballot on Election Day and
then count it up to three days later
it's just getting easier knees or you
guys three weeks three months it's
coming don't give them any ideas stop it
now they just found 10,000 ballots in
the Ami Bera OC race so tell us your
thoughts on where we're going with this
on ballot security on ids the whole nine
yards well my friend John Fonda's with
national review is written about this a
lot and has persuaded me that it's a
somewhat bigger problem than I thought
vote fraud you know you King County
Washington and Seattle in the governor's
race in two thousand and it was two
thousand of four you know they said oh
there's a back cover there's 10,000
violets in there and guess what they're
all voting for the you know there is
there some hanky-panky going on yeah I
mean you know a lot of the Democrats
labor under what I think is an illusion
that you've got low voter turnout
because there's huge barriers to voting
it's actually really easy to vote and
you know you have to show a picture ID
anybody got on a plane without showing a
picture ID by the way get into a federal
building it can't get in without a
picture ID you know the fact is actually
is a percentage of eligibles in recent
years we've had pretty high turnout one
of the interesting things is the biggest
zoom and turnout from one presidential
election of the next in the last 20
years is is in 2004's compared to 2000
the Obama when the first election which
bush was elected 105 million it's 122
million in 2004 in the Obama years
turnout goes from 129 million in 2008 to
126 million in two thousand two thousand
twelve we've got the final figures Ella
for Nia on that now
and so you know the declining turnout
has happened in the era of Obama for
whatever conclusions we want to draw
from that some of the data that's
misleading is people say well the
percentage of eligibles may have gone
down or the percentage of total
population voting is going to yeah it
has because we've got a much higher
person we've got you know thirteen
percent of the people living the country
are non-citizens and now in 1970 that
was about three or four percent when we
had a low ebb of immigration in the
country so if you look at actual
eligibles it's been pretty high so you
know I think there's some problems to be
solved there I think the danger of
people being excluded from the polls is
vastly exaggerated and well you know we
will fight these things out
state-by-state Colorado had that all
mail-in ballot now there have been some
complaints from Republicans that people
didn't check the signatures of the
mailed in ballots there's anecdotal
evidence of campaign workers for
left-wing organizations scouring
wastebaskets picking up mailed in
ballots and then filling them out
gleefully for the Democrats will see
what Colorado now it's got a Republican
state Senate and so forth what they're
going to do about that
during the last two elections we have
really seen a lack of kitchen table
issues being discussed they're not being
discussed by the press and they're not
being there not being focused on to
really allow the people to express
themselves um I want your kitchen table
issue well if you want to talk about the
war on women the the war on women can be
summed up by a number of kitchen table
issues which is do you have a good job
can you put your children into college
does your husband have a good job which
would allow a woman who wants to stay
home with their children it would allow
to stay home the kitchen table issues
that the press just seemed to have they
seem to lack an intellectual curiosity
with the normal questioning and the
normal expiration that goes along with
elections ah do you see any change or I
think I think you got to blame those
guys they were out a bill of rights that
guarantees as a free press but not a
fair one they didn't think of that it's
probably a good thing they did now I
think they actually you know the
sluggish economy was the undercurrent in
this campaign that was that was one of
great force it was a real undertow to
the Democratic Party and you know you
can say where they didn't present enough
statistics oh they didn't do this or
that this is something that people feel
they feel it from their families they
feel it from people around them their
communities this has been a very
disappointing and slow economic recovery
you will get some Democratic economists
that will say well the years from 2001
to 2007 were not as great as some other
economic growth years I think there's
something I think that is an
intellectually serious argument business
formation is down a lot that is
particularly accentuated during this
administration but it's a longer-term
trend as well and it's one that I think
we all need to think about and I think
one of the things that you see some of
these Republicans doing the Marco
Rubio's and mike leigh's the Rick's
nighters and scott Walker's in their
states is saying okay let's look for
some public policies that can push that
can nudge people that can give people
openings to move in a better direction I
don't think anybody is just sitting out
there and saying we have the ultimate
answer I think that those who look back
nostalgically to the Reagan campaign say
well if we just lower taxes on high
earners that's going to solve a lot of
problems it may solve a lot of problems
but it also you know the tax levels are
not as high as when reagan took office
so you're not going to get that kind of
you would probably be wise not to expect
the kind of bounce we had I mean we're
told we should be happy we're getting
200,000 new jobs a month at this point
and three percent economic growth rate
well there was one month in 1983 when
you got a million new jobs oh by the way
the country had 40 million fewer people
had to and you add seven percent growth
rates how we can produce that I think
that's something that all of us need to
think more about and that our public
officials political candidates and even
our political consultants ought to think
about
ok
thank you all i will draw your attention
very briefly to our upcoming lecture on
the evening of tuesday November
eighteenth Stephen cam bone who is the
department defense policy official in
the bush administration speaking on
anticipating history how well China can
control its destiny and it is the herald
a rude moral lecture please join us for
that thank you all for coming
sweet and we're just as having